so as we're now in October the month of
horror it seems like a perfect time to
return to the Cthulhu Mythos and we do
that today with the deep ones a set of
creatures that some of you may be
familiar with and others may just snow
as those weird fish people as of right
now most of what we've covered in this
channel regarding the works of Lovecraft
has centered around the deities of the
mythos the cosmic entities that we
cannot comprehend nor understand but the
deep ones are somewhat easier to explain
with that being said easier certainly
doesn't mean easy those of you who have
read the works of Lovecraft will know at
times it can be more than confusing so
what exactly are they the deep ones can
be broken down to and described as
amphibian like humanoids that dwell in
the very depths of the ocean
considering the very loose cannon of the
Cthulhu Mythos they don't seem to have a
set in stone appearance or form but they
are often described as having a mixture
of human fish and amphibians reigns
their skin is often somewhere between a
dark green and a light gray color their
bellies are white and they have this
noticeable Gloucester them suggesting
that a physical altercation may be quite
difficult and because of how slippery
their skin is the fish I suspect that
are deep ones is very apparent when we
look at their head because it is
basically the head of a fish we see an
array of gills located around the neck
and they have these large globular eyes
that in most cases don't have eyelids
making them incapable of blinking they
also have webbed hands and feet and
their backs are lined with fins and
scales despite the fact that they do
actually have legs their movement rarely
resembles that of a human the instead
move on all fours and at times hop
around like a frog a man-eating
carnivorous frog that is the deep ones
made their first appearance in love
cross 19:31 novella the shadow of
Innsmouth which was then later published
in 1936 until the state remains the only
piece of Lovecraft's work that was
published in a traditional book formed
during his lifetime the story itself
takes place in the fictional location of
Innsmouth
a deserted fish in town we very quickly
learned that those in the town have
quite a weird look to them and they're
definitely not the most welcoming to
strangers will several go in missing
including those sent by the government
to investigate the inner dealings of the
town when the narrator of the story and
our protagonists Robert Olmstead travels
to the town he comes across a local
merchant by the name of Obed Marsh
who discovered this race of fish like
humanoids Marcin took it upon him
of Crater copse known as the esoteric
order of Dagon this cult like many in
Lovecraft's work would are taken human
sacrifice and in exchange the deep ones
would ensure that their fishing holes
are very lucrative even gifting the
people of the town jewelry from the
depth of the ocean oh bird Marsh in his
cult would eventually be arrested and
the human sacrifice then stopped but the
deep ones angered then attacked the town
killing over half of its population the
only way the survivors could guarantee
their safety was by continuing Oh Birds
practices the people of Innsmouth were
then forced to breed with the deep ones
creating these rather odd hybrid
creatures that resembled humans early on
but as they age they slowly transformed
into deep ones they would eventually
leave the surface and live in the
undersea cities so it now makes sense
while the people of Innsmouth seem so
odd to the narrator why they looked and
walked so strangely because most of them
were going through the transformation of
becoming a deep one with an aura to
Robert now knowing too much it's no
longer safe in the town and as he tries
to escape the entire town begin their
search for him after a brief encounter
with some of the creatures Robert was
able to flee and as the years passed he
began to research his own family
bloodline - Robert Schoch he discovers
that he is a descendant of o bird Marsh
and this entire time he himself was
going through a transformation process
of becoming a deep one Robert eventually
comes to terms of his situation and
travels to the deep one city beneath the
sea where he would live for eternity so
now we've gone over the main crux of the
story there are a few things to discuss
and mention the deep ones are immortal
meaning the cannot die of old age and
decay but they can still however be
killed so if the deep ones are immortal
then why they breed in with humans we
may not know their final plan and
endgame but the deep ones aren't the
same as the cosmic entities subscribed
by Lovecraft
if we break them down they're
essentially an alien species a group of
intelligent frog people so we can
attempt to understand their motives and
designs we know that they want to take
over the surface so perhaps freedom of
humans is another way to increase their
numbers on the surface while
destabilizing our own population at the
same time it's also worth considering
that part of the cult sacrifice may not
have been a blood offering but maybe
just an offering of men and women to the
Deep Ones if you have another species
given you their people in exchange for
fish and jewelry then perhaps using them
to breed is the most useful way they can
be used there is some debate as to how
these hybrids are conceived with many
believing that all hybrids come from a
female deep on an
male human the theory behind this is
that female deep ones and male humans
possess the limiting growth gene of
their species which prevents the hybrid
upon some growing at a faster rates than
a regular deep ones which leaves us
wondering what type of monster could be
created from a female human and a male
deep one with all of that said we can
now discuss a transformation process of
a hybrid in some more detail in the
early life we've already mentioned that
they resembled a human and at this stage
they are not immortal so dying of
natural causes before the transformation
is complete is entirely possible later
in life their ears begin to shrink until
they are almost entirely non-existent in
some cases they just completely
disappear their eyes begin to bulge and
almost burst from their sockets no
longer needed to blink they begin to
lose all of their hair and their heads
begin to narrow women starts to form
between their fingers and their skin
becomes rubbery changing color gills are
developed from the folds and their neck
and their voice has become croaky the
actual rate in which one transforms
varies from person to person so there is
no set period for this transformation
process once they have transformed
however it takes some time before
they're able to live underwater so they
go into isolation until they are ready
they eventually abandon the human world
and journey to one of the many undersea
cities the deep ones may not be on the
same level as the deities of the Cthulhu
Mythos but they have been said to do
their bidding the Colton offer off story
was called the esoteric order of Dagon
Dagon himself is often described as an
enormous deep one and he was revered
amongst the deep ones as their deity
it's believed that all Deep Ones
continued to grow even once they've
reached maturity as long as they have a
steady diet so perhaps if enough time
passes the deep ones will be large
enough to take over the surface the
great dreamer Cthulhu was also amongst
the deities that the Deep Ones were said
to follow in the later stories they were
even said to be amongst a species that
protected his daughter Cthulhu so maybe
this association reflects their desire
to see the sunken city of early a once
again rise I know a lot of people have
been asking when I was going to return
to the Cthulhu Mythos and with it being
October most of this month's uploads
will be horror and Halloween related
there will be some more videos on love
cross work along with some classic
horror we also have some original horror
stories that we've written to give you
an idea of the quality of writing or be
in the book which will have its own
trailer up pretty soon if you have
enjoyed this video and there's any areas
of Lovecraft's work that you'd like to
see me cover then please let me know in
the comments
though as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained